it's like a symphony of manipulating and
spinning and flipping the cards in your
hands it's like each move inspires the
next and you're not even thinking about
it
the cards are dancing between the hands
they're spinning around they're flipping
over they're doing things you wouldn't
even expect them to be doing it's just
so surprising almost magical
[Music]
for as long as I can remember we've
always done things in tandem together we
both got into magic around the age of 12
we would go to the library and check out
books by diver Ninh Chi Hollingworth
just seeing the illustrations were like
wow we can do this with playing cards
when we started practicing cardistry it
wasn't a thing it has its roots in magic
it comes from card magicians who would
use what is called the card flourish and
these were used to accentuate certain
moments in a magic trick so we took that
and just ran with it we were the first
to embrace it and really focus on it and
practice it as its own thing and promote
it as its own thing
[Music]
cardistry is very much like
skateboarding you know we practice these
tricks until we have them down perfect
you know we see other tricks and we're
like oh we got to learn that you have 52
playing cards and the possibilities to
to maneuver those around are endless you
can hold a deck of cards in your hand
and it's one solid block
now imagine lifting up another block so
now you have to well what can you do
with those two blocks in your hands well
you can create more blocks and we call
those packets and you can start
maneuvering and spinning and flipping
those packets between your fingers it's
hard like it takes a lot of dexterity
it's all practiced it's all rehearsed
and when you're truly a master and you
can just start doing things on the fly
and you don't even have to think about
it
[Music]
what kids are doing today with cards is
mind-blowing if you would have told me
that when I was 14 years old I would
have been like that's the coolest thing
I had no idea it could even be this big
the ultimate goal would be to get people
to almost put cardistry first when they
see a deck of playing cards you know
it's no longer for games it's no longer
for gambling it's Carter Street we are a
circuit of big family tradition and with
the way we present our show is the same
way that my family presented the show
over 175 years ago there's nothing fancy
about what we do here it's magic real
magic
[Music]
we grew up in a circus as a child you
just step into being a clown thank you
for coming we're a classic family circus
which means our family's here working
together performing together first of
all is my mother the matriarch of our
family then I have my sister Carla who
with her husband Rudy they perform with
her dog act and then way my sister Tosca
she has two horses on the show but she
also directs the show her husband J is
an amazing white clown the white clown
is the straight Club
he's the best white pawn that I've ever
seen
knack that my son and I do right now in
a show is actually a balloon routine
it's nothing new I mean it's thousands
of years old cause haven't done it
forever
it happens to be really cute when he
does it because he's adorable it's an
it's a unexplainable thing to see my
child do what he loves to do I mean this
egg it's a seven-year-old beautiful
little boy and his heart opens up and he
gives it to everybody it's different
here I think the most places when we
come into this ring we become family
I believe circus and family are
basically the same words
a technical machine
I mean Claire come on ba eager Donna
okay type of vet school before you comin
in fifty in Ghana coffins can look like
this they're carved into whimsical
shapes and painted bright colors meant
to represent a person's life or
occupation veggie anon city agua addict
I didn't even know
[Music]
okay bye drive a cab Buddha yeah what's
money
Julio first morning I feel lonely Alan
look we need a yahoo request Manavi
Nellie anon and his family are at the
center of this extravagantly designed
larger than life coffins made in the
shape of whatever one desires papa
Kentucky
is that the mechanism or a d-cup not
good for each morning she gone on it it
started about 65 years ago with an odd
request from a chief to be buried in a
coffin shaped like a cocoa pod from
there the request kept coming in and
anons father realized he had a serious
business on his hands while funerals are
sad occasion in Ghana
many also see them as an opportunity to
celebrate the deceased will maneuver via
oh yeah I feel tomorrow I celebrate oh
yeah no Kuni look away when an order
comes in for one of their coffins they
first get the measurements of the
deceased carve the wood into the shape
of the families choosing create an
opening and stand up for smoothness it
then goes to an artist for painting once
interior stuffed it's ready to be
delivered to the family and these
coffins are not only delivered locally
Los Angeles Gattaca PT DMV democracia as
for non he already has has picked out
this morning I don't know who the were
to snoozin words anywhere
[Music]
there's three things that are most
important to chefs first is flavor
second has flavor and third is flavor
flavor rules
[Music]
built on the Fertile former lakebottom
soil of northern Ohio the chef's garden
is a 300 acre family farm that grows
specialty produce for some of the
world's best restaurants the chef's
garden is a small family farm that has
the good fortune of working directly
with some of the greatest chefs in the
world in many cases we're working with
plant growers that are breeding to be
able to create new plants not genetic
modification but genetic selection the
farm grows produce of all shapes and
sizes
like miniature carrots these white
strawberries in almost a hundred
varieties of microgreens but the Jones
family wasn't always the chef's garden
my parents have had some very successful
years in 1983 they had a very
devastating hailstorm and ultimately the
farm collapsed we were dealt a new deck
of cards and found opportunity within a
disaster we met a European influence
chef iris Balin to grow me varieties for
flavor grow me varieties without
chemical I want a zucchini bloom thought
this lady was absolutely crazy little do
we know she knew a heck of a lot more
about it than we did and that really
opened our eyes to another whole world
out there we hooked up with some really
great chefs early on folks like Danielle
Beaulieu and jean-georges Vongerichten
and Alain Ducasse and Michel Rashard and
then Thomas Keller and Charlie Trotter
and in ritz-carlton chefs and for
seasoned chefs and they've allowed us in
existence in agriculture
we're indebted to those chefs that have
given us the privilege and the path to
be able to follow our dream of farming
so it's that symbiotic relationship of
chef and farmer working together for the
greater good and here we are 35 years
later still working to get better to the
best of our ability right now in this
place I think we're doing the right
thing and I think that trumps every
other reason for whatever you do in this
life
[Music]
people could understand that this is the
kin to the scariest thing you've ever
done then they'll start to understand
why we're so addicted to it when I put
the goggles on first thing I'm doing is
trying to calm down it totally puts you
inside the drone you just forget where
you are
[Music]
I'm Conrad Miller also known as ferati
and I'm a drone racer
I started in September 2014 and that was
like the ground floor
[Applause]
of all the activities I've partaken in
motorcycles and flying drones are on the
same level in terms of intensity it's
cool when you have a hobby and you can
do it and you love it but when you can
share it with your kids I mean that's
just you know that's just like what it's
all about I think ok so props again
flying and racing with sorrell has just
been a pure joy he's a good kid he's a
talented kid and I think it comes easy
to have any kid like that because they
don't feel the pressure that adult to do
good landing come in and hat this is
harder than anything else I've done and
it's because when you're when your
nerves go your fine motor still go kids
don't care there's having fun and they
just learn much faster then of course la
is at the Hawthorne mall which is
abandoned it's been abandoned since the
80s I believe and it looks like a place
where you would go if there was a zombie
apocalypse
[Music]
when I go into races feel like I put a
lot of pressure on myself to win you
know I want all of my practice and all
of my time flying to show for something
I was flying by and I wasn't nervous but
I was just a little too high in crashed
[Music]
everybody is just working really hard to
be the best at it and it's just gonna
get tougher and tougher I take that 180
good Kaden flying with roll now it kind
of gives me an opportunity to look at it
from a different perspective because I
can coach him ready mm-hmm
[Music]
he's aware enough to know that he gets
to do these things that most kids don't
get to do he's flying a drone which is
this groundbreaking thing we hit each
other you hit me what are you talking
about we hit each other you know his
parents we don't always feel like we do
enough I brought him in a drone racing
and he knows he's lucky and he knows
he's fortunate the kid are you going
pretty quick and you know he's just he's
grateful for everything that he gets
you
[Music]